welcome my name is Holly and I'm the UK
head of communication here at CD Projekt
RED and I will be your host for today as
we take a deep dive into cyberpunk 2077
wittingly showing you a video with new
gameplay and new gameplay mechanics and
afterwards I'll be joined by three of
our developers Myles Philip and Pavel as
we take a closer look at some of the
things you're going to see and hopefully
answer some of your questions on behalf
of everybody at CD Projekt RED we're
incredibly excited to share this new
look at cyberpunk 2077 with you
hey V you all right let's do this
you know about what this is
[Applause]
[Music]
what now
funny Johnny
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
where are we I'll BBS data fortress
bridge to the deep net
[Music]
beyond
welcome to the cyberpunk 2077 2019 deep
dive video in last year's gameplay
review we showed you our vision for the
world of cyberpunk 2077 its quests and
visual design this year we'd like to
give you a peek at some of the play
styles you'll be able to adopt as your
character progresses through the story
it was nothing you're about to see
sequences embodying two distinct
approaches to playing Cybermen will show
you a strong solo build that is a
character who focuses on employing blunt
force and taking instant action
and a netrunner bill a play style taking
frequent advantage of stealth tactics
packing and battlefield control achieved
using malicious software
additionally you'll learn more about
Pacifica one of the games districts two
gangs and the animals and the Voodoo
boys and you'll see glimpses of Johnny
silver and the digital construct who
haunts our main character
[Music]
a word of caution given that the video
covers a section of the game deep into
the main storyline we have edited the
footage to contain as few spoilers as
possible be aware that the gameplay as
presented does reveal characters and
locations you'll see while playing the
game's main story our so watch at your
own discretion where we headed
be sweet
in this video you'll experience a
segment of a quest from the middle of
the game we're currently in Pacific one
of night cities six unique districts
Nova scenic our
you guys aren't exactly great of rolling
out the welcome mat for add sex it was
designed to be a tourist hotspot within
the city as you can see this didn't pan
out when uncertainty struck the global
economy investors pulled their funding
leaving most establishments unfinished
it's one of those places where
expectations and reality collided
resulting in a heap of disappointing
ongoing getting wars plagued this part
of the city Outsiders don't come here if
they don't have to even by night city
standards
it's dangerous to those unfamiliar
taking a casual stroll here would not be
a good idea a fast motorbike or
armor-plated car would be the safer
option
but places like this have their
advantages if you're in need of rare
goods or illegal cyberware Pacifica's
bustling local markets are a good place
to start your search the grand imperial
mall is a whole other story it was one
of the last developments in Pacifica to
lose its funding until recently it stood
vacant but now again called the animals
has moved in for reasons unknown and
that's what we need to learn in order to
earn the trust of the Rue du Bois the
animals rivals what the hell could
[ __ ] tell me what you plan to do
first you take job you do what I see
[Music]
of the many gangs in cyberpunk 2077 the
voodoo boys are the most skilled at
using the net why what for you watch
this mysterious game with highly skilled
net runners has close ties to the local
Haitian community you are Pete we have
been waiting patients settled in
Pacifica in the 2060s
after natural disasters struck their
island and forced them to emigrate on
mass the Voodoo boys gang formed around
this same time though at a smaller scale
now the gang effectively rules Pacifica
the voodoo boys don't usually work with
outsiders lucky for us it seems they're
prepared to make an exception this time
mr. Hanson said you got Murph work needs
doing still to earn their trust we need
to prove our worth plac'd one of the
Voodoo boys higher-ups has offered a
submission we need to infiltrate the
grand Imperial mall currently occupied
by the Voodoo boys deadly enemy a gang
called the animals 2035 0 7 3 second
before become your net we try to learn
where they come your net come from the
animals are not your normal game their
presence and Pacifica is suspicious the
value might above all else and where
melee combat implants to raise their
prowess in combat their beverage of
choices juice potent strength and speed
enhancing concoction as sought-after
bouncers they're usually dispersed
throughout town as skilled street-level
business types they've cornered the
market in illegal substances and
underground live or die prize fights
when they converge in one spot it's for
something big it's then they appoint the
fastest and strongest among as their
ad-hoc leader in this case it's a woman
named sasquatch
great dr. Kaufman to admit this is the
tech plac'd was talking about it seems
non-standard for the animals and this is
where we come in getting to the van
won't be easy but were more than
qualified for the job which we can
complete in one of many ways
the character creation in cyberpunk 2077
is the kind you'd expect from a
full-fledged RPG you start by choosing
your past important because this unlocks
special options at important story
junctures you also fully customize your
character using a deep customization
system that spans not only your look and
style but also your abilities cyberpunk
2077 does not feature fixed classes
instead it has a fluid class system that
allows players to mix and match a wide
range of abilities to suit their play
styles you can create a strong solo
character a skilled net runner or any
other hybrid class you can imagine
[Applause]
let's see how a solo play style in
cyberpunk 2077 might work solos prefer a
direct approach they use guns and might
to get these done
so let's reach sematic with our enhanced
strength we can strip this turret of its
weapons
animals a taste of their own medicine
this is how a player investing in solo
abilities might live out their
Terminator power fantasy enhance
strength lets us force open doors
or grab enemies to use as human shields
we also gain access to powerful melee
combat cyberware so even someone as fast
and strong as sasquatch the leader of
this group of animals is not impossible
to beat for a solo Sasquatch has a
different game plan she's out to Jack in
and haggis let's see how this plays out
what's going on
it's our choice if we want to finish her
off or spare her your cyberpunk your
rules
if you'd rather sneak around hide and
strike from the shadows no problem just
develop your net running skills to get
around obstacles or hack into enemy tech
to have it do the dirty work for you
[Music]
med running abilities mean hacking
skills that let us use our cyber deck to
breach access points for this we fill
the buffer of our cyber deck with a
string of instructions represented by
these letters and numbers matching the
instructions for basic access grants us
control of devices connected to this
network the more instructions we match
the more control gained over elements in
the network we can hack our way through
in numerous ways a quick hack may grant
us control of the security camera
another one should let us tweak the
difficulty of the training bot to create
a distraction
[Music]
with our nanowire we can even hack this
guy's implants from a distance
[Music]
in this world almost everything is
connected to a local network and that
means it can be hacked which brings us
back to cyberspace you don't get to do
anything in the net unnoticed there's
always someone watching it could be core
pose or even worse it could be net watch
and that is exactly the case here net
watch and the voodoo boys are like fire
and ice the first of these wants to
maintain the old order and protect
people from AI anarchy originating from
beyond the black wall the voodoo boys
want to establish contact with the free
ai's they believe this will enable their
boundless expansion on the net and grant
them the upper hand over net watch net
watch sees this as the end of the world
both are right hey how you deal with the
net watch agent is entirely up to you do
we side with the gang choosing to be on
that watch his bad side is never wise
but can we really trust the Voodoo boys
as you can see we have many possible
options but in each case we take a risk
think I'll just stick to my food
[Music]
[Music]
didn't work out well in the world of
cyberpunk few things go as planned
and that was just a glimpse of how
complex the branching storyline in
cyberpunk 2077 can get every decision
you make will have consequences your
choices will shape how the world reacts
to you and affect your relationships
with those around you one of those
relationships is special ever heard of
Johnny Silver Hand a rebel rocker boy
who will be your companion throughout
your adventure in night city come on
nobody think they'd give a rat's take
out your look like everyone in cyberpunk
2077 he has his own agenda you'll decide
if he'll be your ally or your enemy
and that chip in your head the one
thanks to which Johnny lives inside your
mind well that's a story for another
time
[Applause]
welcome back now following the Deep
Diver is an awful lot to talk about so I
found three of the very vast but I think
just in case people aren't super
familiar with cyberpunk 2077 why don't
you introduce yourself one by one so
everybody knows who this here listening
to hey I'm miles I'm one of the level
designers at CD Projekt RED hello I'm
Paulo and I'm a lead of the questing and
it's a great pleasure to be talking to
you so I'm Philip and I'm one of their
quest designers so I work really closely
with Pavel over here thank you guys for
being my face I mean my participant
video let's get started because the last
10 where we saw took place in Watson
this time we're in Pacifica they're very
different and that's super important for
Knight City that it feels different so
what do you need to consider as a level
designer when you're building a place
like this right we are diving right into
it so from level design point of view
first is really important to create
these districts is six ones that we have
in that city to be as different as
possible without making it unbelievable
right and we sort of orient ourselves
around sort of how we approached and say
Skelly gear and novigrad no-man's land
in the witcher 3 so we're sort of aiming
for a very noticeable difference and
this has multiple purposes right first
off we want to enhance variety in the
game right would be kind of boring just
to have a lot of the same throughout the
entire city and we have one city scape
so we need to create this kind of
variety and that's actually a really fun
creative process as well and secondly we
need it as a navigational tool that
means that when you as a player move
around the city
should know where you are simply by
looking around and thankfully there's a
lot of lore that we can sort of dissect
and make our own that helps us around
but we also add our own sort of twists
to the whole thing right so in terms of
Pacifica we know that it's pretty pretty
[ __ ] up place if I can say so and in
what I mean with that is that it's
pretty notable that is almost
post-apocalyptic right the district has
a rich history that caused it to
basically fall into disarray after it
was initially meant to become the city's
crown jewel off of tourism but clearly
as you can see from the footage that
actually didn't quite work out that way
and now you actually see things like
burning cars on the streets right and
it's very deserted so much unlike Watson
that we showed last year where the
streets are bustling with people here
there's way less because it's simply a
very dangerous place that you don't want
to really go if you don't have to and
again that's one of these things that
once you enter the district from the
rest of night city you'll actually
notice that right and of course all the
destruction going on and all of the yeah
I mean suffering and pain so what kind
of things are exclusive to Pacifica
because you don't want people to just
come for the class and then leave and
that's it you want people to keep coming
back to its districts so what can people
find there I mean this is what I meant
when I said like it's a very fun process
the thing of these kind of things
because these sort of characteristics
that we give the district directly sort
of birth' the things that you can find
there right and amongst the destruction
you'll still find people living there
right
Pacifica doesn't have a buyer large
Haitian community
each district sort of has a kind of
dominant gang who has taken over there
in the case of Pacifica that would be
the voodoo boys and unlike the Maelstrom
errs that we saw last year the voodoo
boys are actually deeply ingrained
within the community that lives there
and they actually there they're not your
typical sort of street gang in the sense
that they don't really bring a lot of
gun power to find themselves but they
actually specialize in cyberspace
they're obsessed with the mysteries of
cyberspace they've sort of almost made
it their own religion if you will and
they have the reputation of being the
best net runners that you can find in
night city and it's a very cool gang
that v of course our main protagonist
will interact with in several ways how
you will have to find out and I mean
that's just one of many many different
ways you'll really experience Pacific as
I said all these things together the
culture the the visuals the architecture
and the the history really will have
will have will be very distinct to the
district at the same time we're of
course trying really hard to not make it
feel disconnected right there's always a
link it should always be believable
that's one of the sort of core pillars
that we built everything on but this
will make it for a very unique
experience when you delve an adventure
in this district compared to others and
when looking at the stories that we'll
be telling in this exact district who
always make sure that always fits to the
environment to what we want to build so
you know the street stories to do find
their side quests in the main quest that
is actually placed there it always tells
the story of the community of the people
of the characters that are living there
and the patient community right today
they arrived actually in night city
because of the environmental changes
that were happening in the world
Haiti is actually completely flooded and
they have left that they came arrive to
night City to build at the district that
miles just talked about and they
we're left out at the moment when the
corporation's withdraw all the founding
from the Pacifica they were left there
and they build their own community there
and they gave them the deceit they
become the seed for all the stories that
we're telling there so as a player when
you're like investing meeting all those
characters and talking to them you
actually find out and learn more about
them you know through the quests perfect
but let's talk about the more we just
saw in the deep dive video because
that's not linear you've got the
building you're thinking right well the
person who's playing on their game they
might have a more techie style of play
for you but this person might want to go
in all guns blazing how do you design
levels for all these different
playstyles
anything's possible yes yeah we do give
the player a lot of different tools to
use as he goes through a level and that
makes designing these things quite
complex but you know just to sort of
understand our mentality and I can
actually attempt maybe you'll help me
out with this one to go back in our
development well sometime and to really
sort of we came up with this example to
sort of establish this kind of mentality
that we wanted to have when we
approached our level designs in the way
we do our encounters right and the
example was rather simple the goal was
for a player to like to go from one room
to another but the the main way to go
from that one room to another would be
sort of like a door and be it through
like a scanner or our device it doesn't
really matter for the example actually
going through the store would ultimately
result in the player losing his weapons
but the task was to actually kill a
person on the other side of that door
right now we use this sort of example to
sit down and think okay what how will we
do this in all these kind of different
playstyles right so perhaps you know one
way would be to you know convince a god
that would be stationed next to the door
just let you through right
through like sort of like a social kind
of path or you could take the guy out
take I don't know like a pass that would
enable you to go through the door
without actually letting go of your gun
maybe if you are invested as a melee
character actually doesn't really matter
to you you just walk through the door
and then punch the guy on the other hand
side into like a pile of blood or maybe
as a kind of hacker type of character
you try to find a way to breach the
network to disable the device right the
scanner that would prevent your weapons
from using usage allowing you to move
through and then use your guns on
whatever your target is maybe as a kind
of fast solo kind of character you'd be
able to jump out of the window onto
windowsill double jump to the you know
like a balcony and then enter through
the window there and the list goes on
and on with examples that we try to come
up for this kind of door and this sort
of again it's just to showcase how we
sort of think about these levels right
as as you know putting in a problem that
the player has to solve and we give them
a lot of different tools and
possibilities to solve this issue or
bypass it in their own way and that is
how we're hoping to really create an
experience for the player that they feel
inherently is their own right they came
up with a solution given the systems
that we gave them and and they really
get to feel like the badass cyberpunk V
that we want them to feel like it's
actually also a lot of fun to work on
this from a story perspective because
you know as an example in the Wild Hunt
we were already working with very
nonlinear stories but now we also have
this nonlinear gameplay approach and for
us it was always really important to
have these choices and consequences and
we did them in the story you know
anything should matter somehow but now
we can also say okay players have all of
these different choices to solve a
situation so of course there should also
sometimes be some consequences and
that's just on the gameplay side how you
solve it but of course you know the
story should react to it do it just run
into this room and kill a few guys or do
I you know choose a super different
sometimes this can open up a completely
new way to go through a quest so you
know actually I think it added to this
whole layer of non-linearity it had
quite a few let's say more things we
have to do but the thing is it is a
challenge for us but it's actually a
really fun challenge it's actually
really cool to have to come up with all
these ideas and the thing is also our
quests are iterated upon a lot so
there's an example in our quest
designers of course we played them
ourselves
Pavel as our Lee plays them again
directors play them and also you know
most importantly QA plays our quests a
lot and our QA team has really really
good ideas so you know they always think
ok what do I think right now what would
I want to do in this situation and then
we often communicate and this is how
some of the best ideas are actually
created just through going through these
missions over and over again and always
finding some new ways to approach them
and some new ways to you know find
interesting consequences what to happen
afterwards
yeah and that I think sort of ties up
with a whole philosophy of the game
which is the freedom and we have a
freedom on a story layer and maybe I
don't want to talk about it too much
and to spoil it but it but it ties up
with the gameplay very well with like
the way how the levels are constructed
and we're branching in place Phillip
just explained because player has
freedom playing the game you build your
character the way you want and you play
the way and you want and you want the
player to feel this choice you know that
he's doing depending of you know how
skills he's assigning what weapons he or
she is picking and all that and it all
comes together as like you know
fulfilling this ultimate like cyberpunk
fantasy so in the demo we obviously saw
the bike there was a little mention of
the heavy armored car but can you tell
us a little bit more about the kinds of
vehicles that'll be in 505 27 I can tell
you a little bit about it there's of
course many different kinds of vehicles
because we want to create a real open
city of you know city that makes sense
in the Year 2077 so there will be all
kinds of vehicles and of course there's
also you know society is very different
so you know we also have different art
styles that correspond with the
different parts of society so we have
the art style called entropy so as an
example you might see vehicles that are
very useful there to just bring a person
from A to B or you know they're made to
do a job and of course but you know the
player can choose to have them as well
especially if you know the player might
not have that much money yet but there's
also you know super luxury high-end
vehicles on the other side of the coin
so of course you know you as a player
are only limited by what you can afford
that's like real life yeah life is like
what we strive for but yeah you know we
try to strive for variety so you know we
also look like what are the kinds of
vehicles players would want to have in a
cyberpunk game so you know we don't just
have cars you of course also have bikes
like our very own a guy back kusanagi
here one of my favorites it's a very
very cool bike and there's some let's
say surprise vehicles that are still to
be seen in cyberpunk and I don't want to
spoil here but I would say something are
very special that's also dear to my
heart now I really enjoyed but of course
also let's say the super highest
echelons of people in that city they
also have access to a V so flying cars
which is something that you as a player
you're not part of that world but
through specific story moments you might
get to you know write in them sometime
so you know we want to give you a few
different experiences but yeah you can
also of course you know you have your
garage where your apartment is so you
can also have your own vehicle that you
store and that you can call to yourself
so you know you can't call your vehicle
Roche if you want to it's all up to you
but it will be your very own I wonder
how many of these cars are gonna vehicle
broach now that you've mentioned it so
my 50 is massive and that's like a point
we're really trying to make it's a huge
huge city and you kind of want people to
explore it by foot right you could just
walk right from point A to point B if
that's what you want or drive you could
but probably you would get pretty tired
because it's a pretty big place so you
will have to walk a lot so the thing is
you know we do not have loading screens
while exploring the city it's a
completely seamless place you can go you
know wherever you want and of course
Knight city is a very tense place so
there's lots to see
your way but the thing is also you know
as with all things you want to give
players a choice so of course there's
the option to fast travel but the thing
is actually the way we're designing the
city we actually kind of feel like even
when you're playing it ourselves that
fast travel is often just when I play
the game I don't want a fast travel I
want to explore the city because we
actually tried to give you so many
interesting things so many places that
tell a story that look interesting where
you have something to do where you can
interact with things that just just
something new for you at every corner so
I personally don't fast travel a lot I
just drive my bike and I put on some
nice music and I have a good time but of
course you know it's possible and the
thing is also we actually have proper
city planners working here that actually
are planning out night city and you know
how the traffic would work in that city
and how it would actually make the most
sense
how a city like that would actually grow
organically and you know how it would
flow how the traffic would flow through
there so it's actually really
interesting to also just have that part
of game development now as part of you
know cyberpunk 2077 because this will be
very important for how people actually
get to explore it themselves to make the
city feel alive
exactly yeah okay so in The Witcher
everybody who's played The Witcher knows
those question marks on the map those
points of interest you dreamt about them
when you were work you just thought
about them you can't walk past them so
what would be sort of looking at first
cyberpunk you know what are those things
that are gonna be all-consuming so we
are probably not paying attention to the
main story we're gonna be like I've got
to go do that first and I can't go and
do this until I've done that one over
there what will we be finding so in
night city you actually really want to
tie it into the world so as an example
most districts have a so called fixer
like you might know from our gameplay
demo from a year ago there's Dexter
DeSean and people like this they you
know they can give you jobs that also
fit the specific district you're in so
if when you enter a district and you
know you're kind of known as a mercenary
who's doing certain things for money
fixers might contact you and they have
some jobs for you and then these jobs
you know as an example they can be
Street stories and they show up on your
map and you kind of you get them you
know you get an icon so you know okay
this is this kind of street story and we
always
put some interesting story to them
because after Wild Hunt we actually
founded a completely new team the open
world team which is actually creating
some amazing content to actually fill
this world with things that are
meaningful so you know we actually want
to make this that you can do many also
smaller things around the city but
they're actually all cool and unique in
their own way and one cool thing is also
of course they appear on your map but
the map in the game is actually properly
immersive it's that really really cool
looking point cloud version of night
city and you can see the tasks from your
fixer there but the cool thing is
actually because you know you're a
character in cyberpunk here.we and you
actually have this information so it's
not just the player seeing them it's
actually your character seeing them as
well because it's all part of the world
so we want to give you this full
immersion yeah is actually really really
cool for us that with the street stories
and all the other content we're
essentially sort of giving him like
almost are which are three side quest
treatment in the sense that even simple
tasks can be fun and exciting if we pack
them up in a cool story and route them
within the world right we can use these
street stories to to expand further on
how life in night city and the world of
cyberpunk in general works and sometimes
this might even be a better staging
ground than the the main story itself
right we're just like a let's see how
everyday life works in this kind of
aspect from this perspective in this
scenario and actually that's again like
first that's a lot of fun and it's a
very exciting process and I hope that
when players play it at the end that
they will actually find a sort of
enriching they experience because they
always kind of have this impression like
hey wow no matter where I go things are
actually worked out right it's never
just a simple sort of task of hey do
things like but there's always a reason
there's always an understanding of why
you're doing things and even in those
few scenarios where it might seem a bit
more you know oblivious you'll usually
find that you know there's more to it
than meets the eye
yeah and one interesting thing about
those three stories is also that you
know our main stories of course your own
personal journey through night city but
a street stories are actually because
you know you play a mercenary who's
trying to carve their
through the city this is actually your
job so this is actually the role you now
inhabit in this city sorry actually
you're part of that system through these
three stories and through working with
fixers so it's actually this whole
different way of playing you know the
game and feeling immersed in the city
can't wait to lose my life time so in
the deep dive we can see that the
character has three sort of origins that
we can pick I mean what are they and
they actually affect the gameplay oh
okay
you like yes okay I'll go into my 15
minute answer okay so we actually call
them life paths and those are the origin
stories that player can pick and it's
actually three of them so you can be a
street kid it can be a nomad or you can
be a corporal now each of them actually
defines the beginning of the story for
the players so you start in a completely
different way than other life paths and
you are slowly introduced into that
story you know at different people you
are ended completely different place in
life you're in different place in night
City and your stories slowly you know
you get involved into that whole thing
with chip and Jonah's overhand and
eventually you know you're lander but
you actually start off being a
completely different person now what is
important with that is we actually take
that through the whole game and you as a
player you can actually associate
yourself with like nomads you can
associate yourself with a corporate
people or you can be a part of the
streets and it's really up to you you
know what path you want to pick through
the main story and with our best in a
quest team to like support all those
like three I would say main ways to go
through this story and of course player
can like mix and match any time you know
any way he really wants seemingly once
but it's something that we take from the
very beginning till the very end and
what's important there is when you're in
the scenes with the characters so when
you are discussing things you can
actually use those those things so if
you're in corpo and you know how the
corporation's work you know whether
there are no methods you know what's the
deal with them you actually can use this
knowledge and sometimes get something
more you can actually unlock side brand
in the dialogues and you can unlock some
branches in the whole quest sometimes
and this is a bit exciting I would say
it's something like the way how we have
to make sure that the player can
roleplay their character you know to
become that that person and in the demo
that we have we have shown in recording
you can you can see you know this this
moment when you choose you know that
character that you're you are becoming
later in the characters that you are
meeting in the main story they are also
representing those different groups you
know so in the first demo a year ago we
have shown Meredith out you know a
personally know she is a high-class
corporate woman from a mealy texture
there's a lot of power also a lot of
responsibility and you are on her way
and you can see you know how that
interaction looks like so if you're when
you are from corporation maybe there's
something you can do a bit more with
hair you know in that dose also for
others you know for nomads and for force
treaties one of the nice things is
actually also that you know you're not
bound to stick let's say with the
corporates or with the streets so as an
example I can give an example I started
as a street kid game and I always I know
I have my knowledge but then I play
through the story and I notice like I
kind of like these corporate characters
I like that life so you know I can just
you know betray the streets and snuggle
up with the corporates but you know this
is kind of the role playing freedom we
want to get but you know as always this
can also have consequences for you so
anyone who's a plate
the original tabletop version of
cyberpunk is used to the idea of
assigning attribute points to create a
character now in the deep dive video we
just saw we've got a little glimpse of
that screen you could see the points of
the different things so help me
understand how that works and how you
gain those points so it was a player you
build your character at the beginning
assigning those attribute points and
then define like the core
characteristics of your character so how
much body strength you have or how much
reflexes you have or how cool you are
you know that's one of the interesting
stats that we have right but then as you
have those attributes you also have a
skills the skills define a bit more
interesting profession
for you as a player what you can do and
for instance one of those skills is
assassination or the cold blood and
maybe I'll stick to the cola to explain
a bit more so this is a skill that
allows the player to survive in a really
tough situation so at the moment you
know when you get a lot of damage then
the cold-blood skill kicks in thanks to
your cool stat it kicks in and gives you
a boost in damage and then as a player
you can you know survive and so on but
then you know using that skill so you
sort of like use by learning like using
that skill you can actually get better
pump up levels there and you can get
different perks now what's interesting
there you can actually give completely
different perks to the skill that you
have and here I think I could use the
example of the Athletics attribute so
the athletics is a way for us to move
dead bodies so it's a player who can
basically pick up the dead body that you
have just made well it's basically
killed pick it up and like stuff it into
the fridge or in a trash bin now as a
player you normally have slowed down
when you're moving around with the
bodies but if you have added special
perks to your at the athletic skill you
can now run with the dead body so
because you are more athletic you can do
that and those are like three levels of
complexity in our character in building
the character we have we have their
attributes you have the skills and then
you assign perks to it and those three
come together to allow you to create
your own amazing character that you want
to play a lot of people think this if
maybe how cool you live again it's all
about the jacket you're wearing but the
cool fat is not a style based of it well
you know this is cyberpunk so being cool
is of course very important but the
actual cool stat really means how cool
you are under pressure how much you have
control over your body so you know are
there people shooting at me and I'm
holding my gun like that probably not
very cool so this is you know this is
the kind of thing that cool actually
controls but of course you know if you
want to play a character it's actually
cool you have your choices right you can
you can wear your nice leather jacket
and of course you know like in real life
also depends on how you talk to people
and that's of course also the choice of
you as a player you just might freak out
the gunfight cool on the surface but
that's so much so in the deep dive we
saw a quick clip of the inventory screen
it looks like a proper old-school RPG
screen you know with the little blocks
of the system and I know the community
wants to share more about what they can
expect so tell us more mouths well I
will now of course like how I always say
is you know in Sarpong the inventory
screens of course where we manage our
items right but most importantly instead
of funk it's where we also manage our
style and just as Philip just touched on
you know like it's really important for
us to be able for you to be able to
realize your character and that of
course comes in the character creation
but also the way you dress your
character right we're pretty much aware
that there is sort of this in most RPGs
there's this common sort of disconnect
between the stats on an item and the
looks while we can't go into details
here let's just say we're aware of this
sort of you know conflict I guess of
interest sometimes so we're looking into
how you would be able to make a
character still look cool despite having
the best stats of an item right and just
goes to show that that is really
important to us and of course you know
the whole role-playing aspect goes even
further because we'll we'll have some
customisation options not only for the
way you look like but also your guns
right and the inventory will of course
decide what kind of weaponry it is that
your character uses to kill people with
or or sneak into two different in basis
locations because of course it's also
why we mention cyber wear and all of
these little things brought together
again they've sort of allow you to
fulfill your you're sort of what he
calls character fantasy that's the word
I was looking for in the inventory yes
we're changing our clothes we want to
look super cool but what about cyber
where can we do anything with five word
from the inventory screen oh yes so
imagine imagine inventory screen right
so if you see the player there you have
a slot so normally in like let's say
fantasy game you would equip a armor
right or you would equip I I don't know
a lag piece or something like right now
here you can actually replace that with
a cyber wear right so you can get your
legs replace to your cyber legs right
and those can you can give you the
different skills like let's say double
jump but then as a player you can
upgrade actually those and let's say
enhance them in a way that they give you
something special to it so for instance
you can actually make them jump in a way
they do not emit that much sound and
they become like a like a really stealth
tool so because of that you can traverse
in a quiet way through the locations so
this is how you actually upgrade your
character if you just go over your body
and replace whatever you need and
in the Lord there are reproduction you
have to install those core pieces of
Cybermen like for instance the Raven
control system that allows you to
control the flat head but there are also
other pieces that you can do on your own
and on top of that as a player you can
also find pieces small pieces called
shards and those if you slot into your
slot you can actually they give you a
power of a given cyberware so you can
try it out so as a player you can
experiment a bit you know and see how it
would be if I would have installed you
know some special pieces of cyberware in
my body and that allows the player to
you know to see stuff to figure it out
to build their character the way they
want okay so we know we can equip some
of our cybernetic enhancements in the
inventory but like where do we get them
like how do we get more enhancements
alright there's actually multiple ways
of going about that right the most
obvious one is going to a so-called
Ripper doc and getting new cyber a built
in you or enhancing the cyber wear that
you have some of it you will actually
get through your as you adventure
through
night city things like the kouachi IM
plan that we have riots it's almost
mandated on top of you because it's sort
of like a core gameplay mechanic to be
able to scan things and get additional
information on certain circumstances and
of course then we also have something
called a street cred system right so as
you progress throughout the game you
will also unlock more street cred for
your actions and that will enable you to
unlock more content in the game that
means you know more vendors will open up
to you
more servers as well people will have
heard of you and now more willing to
work with you so there's actually
multiple ways this affects your
experience and one of them being you
know like the cyber way that you have
access to so netrunner was featured
pretty heavily in the deep dive but can
you give us a little bit more insight
into some of the combat skills or
ability to come with the idea of
building a net runner yeah so I think
using net running skills gives you lots
of let's say opportunities to be very
creative in how you play the game so I
can just give a few examples so we have
access points and access points are you
know in the world of cyberpunk they can
control all the different devices in the
area which of course is a net runner is
pretty useful because you can hack that
access point and if you full of
successfully do that you can now use
quick hacks you can actually from a
distance take over different devices
like as an example a camera you can do
many different things with it look
through the camera and have a completely
different view or just you know turn it
off if it's in your way and of course
you know you can take over a turret and
make it fight for you or you can do many
different things you know we also tried
to come up with nice custom things you
know depending on where you are let's
say if you're in a gym or there's some
nice boxing robot of course you know
maybe you can do some fun things with
that so I think it's a netrunner it's
always lots of fun to use different
things and as an example if I would use
lots of Medtronic stoves their skills is
also really useful to use lots of cool
skills that make me really good at
stealth so I'm you know really under
control so netrunner can be really good
at you know also using distractions like
if there's a vending machine just make
it spit out some drinks and then of
course you know might some people might
look after death but the thing is a net
runner
isn't you know just a stealth character
there's also cool aggressive net running
abilities because you know we always
want to give you the choice of how to
play so we have here nanowire cyberware
which is really good at hacking enemies
from a distance and then actually taking
over their cyberware so you know most
people in this world have cyber in their
body so just like access points very
good times for net runners so you can
then control that cyber where and also
do some nice things like you know as an
example hack someone's cyber where in
their hand and make them do some things
they might not want to have happen to
them but the thing is also the nanowire
of course it's a wire it's nano it's
very you know sharp so you can also use
it as a weapon or as a whip and you know
the netrunner can be very effective and
using his skills in combat as well so
it's all just you know your choice as a
player what about let's say this all
sounds amazing let's say you want to do
slightly non-lethal because in the deep
dive we did so with squats a squash at
the end there was an option you know do
you want to put our misery or do you
want to let her live so how do people
play like a non-lethal playthrough can
you know can you build a class to help
you do that mm-hmm so that's basically a
choice we maybe really set okay
cyberpunk it is a very violent world but
you're a role-playing your character you
can choose to play the whole game
without killing a single person and of
course you know we're always saying this
should also have an effect on the
stories or certain characters you know
in a quest might ask you you know yeah
please do this thing for me but you know
don't don't make too much trouble and of
course you know you don't get a game
over if you do a thing that the
character doesn't wanna so but the story
will react to it and we want to give you
that choice but of course you know not
only the netrunner is able to do
non-lethal playthrough every player
however you want to skill your character
you're able to do it somehow but of
course it also depends you know where
you are let's say if you're in some
random ruin that doesn't have lots of
met running abilities of course the
netrunner
still has ways to do it but you know he
might not be able to use all of his net
running skills but another player who
has skilled different ways now has a
different experience but you know it can
happen vice versa but what we always
want to say you can finish the whole
game you can finish the quests without
killing a single person sometimes you
just have to also you know think of
because the thing is night city isn't a
very peaceful place so you can never
play like a full pacifist who's never
engaging in any kind of combat because
you know people will attack you
sometimes but you can choose to you know
not kill them because you know like in
real life sometimes if there's attacks
you don't immediately kill everyone you
can solve situations in different ways
yeah all right one thing I'd actually
like to add to that is that we're trying
really hard to not actually punish
players for the playstyle they chose to
do right whether is that you're playing
a lethal or non-lethal or you know like
more aggressive versus a more subtle
kind of approach and while NPCs might
sort of have certain wishes for you how
to approach this situation it will never
outright punish you for not you know
sort of doing their wishes because we
really want to give players as much
freedom as possible and you know taking
punishing the players for certain
actions like that which is basically
them choosing to play that character
would directly contradict this kind of
idea that we're trying to set up in
terms of role-playing fantasy nothing
worse and like accidentally flipping on
the trivia like I didn't mean to kill
them and then everything and as an
example you can also see a sasquatch
that we show in our demo it's a really
intense fight but actually if you choose
you can subvert that fight you can maybe
just you know sneak around her and find
a different solution and then maybe you
know of course you can get a consequence
out of that because now Sasquatch is
still alive so you know the story is
already different so I think this opens
up many different opportunities just not
just for the gameplay but also for us as
storytellers
let's tell us a little bit more about
the solo builds because that was another
build from in the deep dive what kind of
skills of that give someone then as
opposed to Network I think that the most
typical like solo fantasies that that
our players have is to be a strong solo
and to be fast solo so being a Glary
different like I would say so but you
can also build any type of hair behind
you want but the strong one is the
person who can lean on like shaft people
into the trash bins and so on carry
bodies run with them but you can also
like pick up the gear heavy guns you
know the mountain
today to deterrent and like use it
against you know the opponents like we
have we have shown that in the recording
for a moment you know when when V is
like just you know like killing
everything on her way with this very
heavy gun you of course cannot like take
it to your inventor and run around with
everything air with it everywhere but
this is the only like I would see build
that allows you to do that right so this
is very very special however even like
as a fast solo you have access to lots
of different traversing skills so as an
expressive means of exploration you can
for instance do the double jump and
access places that you would not have
otherwise right you can also you know
like slide around with katana or like
slide around using nanowire that we have
also shown so you can be built in it
completely in completely different ways
built based on the stats that we have
picked as a person it sounds really
really cool I'm just gonna run in I
think and just punch everything until I
get what I want which is also like real
life yeah this game is so close to real
life incredible actually literally
happens every day so you know we've
talked about net runner and solo and
we've shown both of them in our deep
dive but that's not just it right like
there are other bills so so maybe tell
us about Teddy yeah um so generally how
we approach this kind of stuff is we
have sort of thought we're thinking of
three sort of main archetypes of how you
can play the game that would be the net
runner place to write the solo play
style we just publish that sort of
branches into sort of more agile fast
solo and the more brutish strong solo
character and then there's the last one
which is the techy again it's just
important for us to say that these are
just archetypes that you know help us
think about how players might approach
any kind of situation but of course
you'll be able to create any kind of
hybrid and just pick the skills that you
like in between and the techy you know
it's sort of a more technically
affiliated play style right whereas the
netrunner is the one that sort of
manipulates devices are active by it by
hacking networks and taking over control
the
techie is actually the one that sort of
dabbles with the hardware itself and
cables and and whatever drives machinery
all that stuff and to add on top of that
we're actually layering our little buddy
called flathead and he is what we call a
spider bot a kind of very sophisticated
piece of military hardware and that the
player will be able to use when he
chooses to to you know invest into the
techie playstyle and cycle is an
interesting one because he's pretty like
basically like this autonomous robot
that listens to your commands and you
can basically send out flathead to do
certain things for you right you might
be able to send them out to manipulate
certain devices right there might be I
know
small with an example here um there is
some sort of like broken broken lamp or
something or like a broken gadget you
can see it with your scanner right and
you might actually send flat hat to do a
little bit of tweaking there to make
that object fall down onto an enemy
right or or other examples would be to
use for her to you know directly engage
with enemies there's a certain
customization options that might be tied
to to a buddy robot and I hope actually
players will so get like oddly attached
to their little robot buddy right and
and again this is like a whole sort of
layer and another layer of how you might
play the game and as I said earlier with
us thinking of the archetypes it is like
one of the possible many many possible
ways of how to play the game and we're
trying to add as many tools as we can
for all three of these archetypes to
really sort of be able to manipulate the
game world and and feel like yeah this
this world you know if I look around I
see opportunities that suit me you know
you've maybe fantasizing to play as a
sort of terminator kind of character
right we have our scanner you look
around see opportunities and you sees
them and
and how you see them and what
opportunities arise where it really just
depends on what kind of character you're
playing and what skills you have
invested in okay so we all stand
flatheads we know that flat head is
everything but also let's talk about
actual weapons let's talk about guns
what can we expect we saw a few we saw
the military being ripped out uses a
machine gun we saw the nanowires but
tell us a little bit more so our guns
are divided into three like main
categories right there is a there are
smart guns that we have shown in a
previous demo like a year ago so
basically they shoot like homing bullets
they're following target
there are also tech weapons and the tech
weapons are those that have like
additional capabilities to them that
they take for instance can pierce covers
and they're also power weapons and power
weapons are mainly focused on being a
street threat great weapons so they
basically have additional skills and
capabilities connected to the fact that
we worked in some way so for instance
those are like bursting shotguns and
things like that and we have put plenty
of work to making sure that the weapons
feel well and they have their weight and
there's lots of really cool examples
that I can give here for instance you
know there is a handgun that as you use
it it actually speeds up the bullets
slowly and and longer you use it faster
the bullets become so they can do more
more things and they can do more damage
if there is for instance like a class of
the weapons for a handgun that is that
has been created by Russian company to
fight cyborgs and that weapon like is
able to heat up the bullet to the point
that the bullet becomes almost like a
melted plastic and it's done for
instance we can shoot off you know
cyborgs arms and so on so oh there's
always like a small piece of story you
know wrapped up around the weapon you
know what what that weapon does and
what's interesting here I think is that
you can also use like a second firing
mode for a weapon and not all weapons
have them but some of them if you use
them in a specific way let's say a tech
rifle that we have shown in the previous
demo when you like when you use it in a
specific way it changes its way it like
collapses together and then it allows
you to pierce up the covers and shoot
through the walls and shoot the enemies
like that or you can you know bounce
bullets of the walls right using the
ricochet so it although we try to always
put enough depth into the gun for
instance I like literally today I have
seen like awesome shotgun that has eight
barrels and there shoots them in the
same time and it has like a actually our
I think that players will love our
gameplay especially the way how the guns
look and how they feel when you should
be I'm sorry fired that yeah shotguns
they're my favorite eight barrels even
better I think also something really
cool to add to this is that you know as
you already touched on it like all these
companies these gun manufacturers and
other stuff they actually I mean a lot
of it comes from the actual law right
but we're also making sure that you know
there's a history to everything that
includes the the brands and ads that we
haven't get in the game we actually have
like a whole team dedicated to just that
kind of stuff and again it's sort of is
in line with our philosophy to make sure
that everything is rooted in the world
has its reason why it is there has its
history I think that's really sort of
like the secret ingredient to make like
a really believable world that when the
player actually goes in there they have
this impression like yeah this place
exists right this feels alive and I
think that will make just the fact of
simply walking through night city like a
really really cool experience so
actually one of the cool things we also
have is we have lots of different melee
weapons and you know it starts by you
know very spontaneous one so let's say
you find a broken bottle and you just
use it or you find a knife on the ground
and you can use it to fight Bailey or
you can as an example throw it but you
can also specialize in melee weapons
because as we said earlier maybe you
want to play as a cyber ninja and of
course there's a cyber ninja there's
many different katanas that you can
actually also specialize and getting
really good at them and there's even
cyber where for melee like the gorilla
fists that can also be used to you know
be really strong and open doors but you
know if you're really strong you can
also hit people with it
a cool thing is also using your melee
weapons together with special cellular
so there's an example my favorite side
where that I always like to use is to
send Davis time and essentially it slows
down time for you because your reflexes
get boosted so now you have superhuman
reflexes and the way we show it is of
course time slowing down for you as a
player so imagine you have your katana
and you just go into a slide and you can
aim and like just go through and it
actually feels really cool like you feel
like you have super control but actually
you can also see as an example in the
demo how it feels like to be in the
receiving end of cyber wear like that so
the animals have reflex boosting so
everywhere as well so actually sometimes
when they're coming to work so in melee
they sip around really fast that is
exactly and this is how it actually
feels for enemies when you have your you
know slo-mo this is how they see you
moving around so it can be pretty scary
to also find someone who uses the same
cyber where you use what about you to
them what about what are your favorite
five ways that you've seen so far then
you can talk about so far before you get
me in trouble oh I think that at least
for me I think those those are gonna be
mantis plates I think that's that's the
best one we have shown how it looks for
the player how it feels when you use
them you know the way you can chop off
heads and so on it's something of a boy
very poetic I would say yeah and then in
another cyber where I think that I would
like it's more story later than mr. stud
I will let our players to figure what it
does for those who know the lore for me
Phil already took it away by by taking
the strong arms earlier and the Sun it
is done so bit of a greedy dude over
there no but so yes technically this
cyber deck is a side piece of cyber well
right that's the one that actually
allows you to to breach Internet whereas
take over control and you know use all
that the hacking magic on all kinds of
enemies right like in the in the
gameplay we show how you can not only
manipulate this training robot but you
can also manipulate devices that you
might not think are necessarily hackable
like the the bench press
that we showed there and it goes even
further than that right if you combine
that with like four examples of
nanowires but also you can do it from
from closer up you can actually breach
into like a squads internal network by
hacking directly into the personal links
of of enemies and once you're in the
squad Network you can actually use what
we call daemon software and to
essentially quick hack the cyber where
that is attached to people's bodies
right so imagine a scenario where you
know you're in it Runner kind of
character you're sneaking through but
then things get home right so now you
find yourself in a combat situation
luckily of course you come prepared you
already foresaw that things might might
go wrong because you're a skilled net
runner after all so you already breached
into the squad's internal network
now these enemies start swarming you and
what do you do of course you start using
your scanner and you look at these guys
and you realize hey I breached the
security so I can now upload my virus
software into these guys to make them do
things that they don't necessarily want
you might tack their cybernetic hand to
force them to pull the pin on a grenade
they have at their you know grenade belt
I'm setting him to fiery and explosive
but spectacularly looking death and
alternately we also have one that you
can actually use to basically make
enemies finish themselves off right to
shut themselves down and it's actually
cool because you sort of see them
struggling with their hand as well so
it's like you really sells the fantasy
of what you're doing right and you're
basically becoming this cybernetic God
as soon as you take over a network and
it really is something that you know
feels so different from the other play
styles that we have and and I really
like the sort of level of variety that
we offer players in
when it comes I think that ultimately
and pardon me for being a bit buzzed
worthy about this but like this will
really make each playthrough very unique
to players right not only the way you
play it the way you interact with the
world the way you talk to people all
that kind of stuff like you if you look
at all the little choices that
accumulate through the game no place
where will basically be like another and
and inherently they will also feel very
differently depending on what kind of
you know character you you want to play
and I guess that would be the more less
obvious one because as a net runner
you'll always be sort of having your
cybertek because otherwise you could not
be a net runner and then I think I've
mentioned before in a nother video
sources I really really like our
nanowires which go hand in hand sort of
with this net running player I guess you
can see where my preferences personal
preferences lie don't worry does not
affect my designs
I try to be balanced but you know like
whereas the regular netrunner can sort
of reach into a squat network by sort of
taking an enemy out and having an extra
option to breach into into their Sports
Network the nanowires actually allow you
to do this from a distance or from a
safe spot right and they can also be
used to slice people into bite-sized
pieces so again as Philip said much
earlier if I remember correctly we've
been doing this for a bit there's
actually you know no place to that is
sort of meant to be played in a certain
way right we don't go okay the hacker
kind of character he's the stealthy guy
he needs to operate from the shadows
whereas the the solo type he's the one
that you know just goes out and shoots
everyone no you can actually still
within these play styles choose how you
play the the kind of character lethal
non-lethal stealthy and non stealthy and
we just give you the tools and all place
else to do whatever you want with it
right so if you want to be a combat
netrunner if you will that likes to use
gunfire and you know making people blow
themselves up
sure go do that but you can also do it
in a stealthy approach it really lies in
the players hands so let's say I've got
my eight bow shotgun it's my bet it's my
favorite gun I love it what can I do to
it can I customize it is it model is
there any option for you know really
making something special and
one-of-a-kind so I think we can say that
there are like two major ways what you
can do how you can customize your guns
one way is customizing the visuals and
those are different skins and like paint
overs paint jobs that they can have on
your gun just to make sure that you know
when you're a cupid that your rifle is
pink or or purple you know if you really
want it but then there's the second way
how you can customize it it's a
different sort of attachments that you
can have you can have silencers you know
you can have like a sniper rifle zoom on
the gun you also can boost up the stats
of the given weapon so in that way you
can basically make it more efficient so
you can make it to look the way you want
and you can make it the shoot you it was
I think mozzie mentioned mister for that
also changes the animation right if it
progresses you can change the way it
looks as you reload and things like that
yeah so basically the the more you use
your guns who figures the better you
become at shooting them right you might
start as in complete amateur like I
would be with shooting a gun I'm not a
very good shot and the the the better
you become with it you know that
actually affects your way of handling a
gun so you know your like your crosshair
might become smaller indicating that
your your accuracy increases ever so
slightly and that will also sort of
influence the the way your your
animation looks like your reload speed
will be faster and all that time so you
actually reget this the sense of
progression and your character evolving
as you play the game and yeah I think
that's pretty special sort of experience
but if
combine it with the way you know that
you can customize your guns amount and
kind of really have this feeling that
yeah this is my signature gun right and
I'm really good with it right guys thank
you so much I know there is one thing we
haven't talked about from the demo and I
was a little bit more about the gangs we
spoke with the foodie boys a bit but we
haven't even really spoke about the
animals and I know you guys know
everything about cyber phones I thought
I'd actually throw out two maybe the
Godfather himself so I clapped with Mike
pon Smith at Gamescom to ask him who are
the booty boys and who are the animals
I might even the white pasta that I'm
the guy who killed your cyberpunk
characters and today I'm going to talk
to you about two very important things
I'm gonna talk to you about animals and
i'ma talk about voodoo boys so let's
take the voodoo boys when I created them
many many years ago I was looking at
kind of a really interesting idea which
is what we were now called cultural
appropriation what happens when somebody
comes in and tried to adopt a culture
that they know little or nothing about
and does it really badly but one of the
great things about having a few years is
that you get a chance to do some reduce
and one of the best ones is what we have
with Buddha boys now the Buddha boys in
2077 are really Buddha boys they
inherited the name but it was sort of a
natural fit they were coming from Haiti
and diminished Dominican Republic and
they were the real thing and they
managed to take a lot of the elements of
their original culture and melded into
the world of 2077 bring that cyberpunk
pie into a very old and respected
culture so they're a gang but they're
not really they're more of a cultural
phenomenon they're more a way of
cultural exploration
and I think it's really cool because it
shows us a side of the cyberpunk future
that we normally wouldn't see on the
other hand they're the animals
way way back in my dark dank past I used
to lift don't anymore but I used to and
I would see guys like the animals in the
gym I went to guys who lived to get
strong and get really strong and get
really strong the animals are like those
guys they're in it to basically build
themselves up become the Tigers of their
particular urban jungle they want to be
big they want to be bad and they want
you to fear them just because they exist
and you know it's really easy to fear a
guy who blots out the Sun when he walks
by you but the animals are very simple
they have a neat those get big lift get
strong lift
so unlike the Buddha boys who have a
culture the animals have a think and
contrasting that is interesting because
in 2077 you get a chance to see that not
every gang is the same as every other
gang and what motivates them depends on
the people you meet on the street check
it out this Mike possum is saying I'm
still here to kill you start from here
we hope you enjoyed our deep dive into
cyberpunk 2077 now don't forget you can
join us on Twitter Facebook forums and
even join us on this core to make sure
you stay up to date on all of our news
cyberpunk 2077 is launching April 16th
2020 and is available for pre-order now
on behalf of everybody working on
cyberpunk and here at CD Projekt RED we
thank you for watching your ongoing
support and we can't wait for you to
explore night city
[Music]
[Music]